tenemos aquí tres ecuaciones con cuatro
variables desconocidas y al igual que en
el primer vídeo de esta serie pues
queremos resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones pero al menos mi intuición me
dice que la solución no va a estar muy
restringida o sea porque hay menos
ecuaciones que variables desconocidas
entonces tal vez tal vez mi intuición me
dice que puede haber una cantidad
infinita de soluciones pero pues hay que
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones para
ver qué es lo que pasa realmente no
entonces al igual que en los dos vídeos
anteriores de esta serie pues vamos a
hacer la matriz aumentada de
coeficientes de este sistema de
ecuaciones entonces los coeficientes en
cada una de las ecuaciones de la
variable x1 son 1 1 2
entonces la matriz aumentada de
coeficientes tiene aquí un 1
2 los coeficientes de la variable x2 son
224 en la primera ecuación es 12 en la
segunda ecuación es un 2 y en la tercera
ecuación es un 4 de la x 3 es 12 y como
aquí no hay ningún x 3 entonces podemos
pensar que por aquí hay 10 veces x 3 y
entonces ya los coeficientes son 120 ok
vamos a borrar esto
pero aquí va a un 1 2 y 0
y los coeficientes de la variable x 4
son 1 - 1 y 6 1
- 1 y 6
y del lado derecho del igual hay un 8 un
12 y un 48 en la primera ecuación 12 en
la segunda ocasión y 4 en la tercera
ecuación
ok entonces esta es la matriz aumentada
de coeficientes de este sistema de
ecuaciones y pues hay que ponerla en su
forma escalonada reducida por filas
entonces lo primero que podemos hacer es
hacer que estas dos entradas de la
matriz se vuelvan cero y para hacer eso
pues vamos a empezar por volver a
escribir la matriz aquí va a estar
nuestra matriz y pues vamos a dejar la
primera y la tal cual como ésta
a 21
y después va esta línea que básicamente
lo que representa es la línea de iguales
de aquí y después nuestro 8
y para hacer que esta entrada sea 0 lo
que vamos a hacer es reemplazar esta
fila este renglón por esta fila menos
una vez esta fila porque uno menos uno
es cero y es justo lo que queremos
entonces uno menos 10
después 2 - 2
eso también es 0 y pues ya con este 0
aquí podemos creer que la variable x2
que es representada por esta columna va
a terminar siendo una variable libre no
tal vez porque para que ésta no sea una
variable libre necesitamos una entrada
pivote en esta columna pero mejor en
lugar de andar asegurando cosas vamos a
terminar de convertir a esta matriz a su
forma escalonada reducida por filas
entonces 2 menos una vez 1 eso es un 1
- 1 - este 1 eso es menos dos menos 2 y
12 menos 8 esos 4
entonces vamos con este renglón queremos
hacer que esta entrada se vuelva 0 por
lo cual vamos a reemplazar esta fila por
esta fila menos dos veces esta fila ok
entonces dos menos dos por uno
eso es dos menos 20
4 - 2 x 2 o sea 4
4 eso es 0 también
0 - 2 x 1 eso es menos 2 - 2
6 - 2 x 1 6 2
eso es 4 4
4 - 2 por 8 2 por 8 16 y entonces
tenemos 4 menos 16 o sea tenemos menos
12 menos 12
ahora veamos nos podemos deshacer de
este término o sea hacer que este
término se vuelva a cero
ok y para eso vamos a dejar esta fila en
su lugar que es la que tiene esta
entrada pivote
0 0 1 - 2 la línea del igual y después
un 4 y queremos que esta entrada sea 0
bueno sabes que de hecho creemos que
esta entrada y esta entrada sean 0
porque porque esta entrada es la entrada
pivote de esta fila ok
entrada pivote es la primera entrada
distinta de 0 entonces este 0 este 0 y
esta es distinta de 0 así es que esta es
la entrada pivote y si queremos que
nuestra matriz está en su forma
escalonada reducida por filas
entonces para empezar tenemos que hacer
que esta entrada sea un 1 cosa que ya
está y además tenemos que hacer que
todas las entradas de la columna de
nuestra entrada pivote sean igual a 0
así es que tenemos que hacer que ésta
sea cero
esta sea cero así es que vamos a
reemplazar esta fila por esta fila menos
una vez esta fila aunque hay entonces
uno menos uno por cero esto sigue siendo
un 12 menos 0 esto es 21 menos 1
eso es 0 que es justo lo que estábamos
buscando
1 - menos 2 eso es uno más 2 o sea 3
y 84 eso es 4 y ahora para hacer que
esto se vuelva a 0 pues lo que vamos a
hacer es reemplazar esta fila por esta
fila más dos veces esta fila así es que
cero más dos veces cero eso es 00 más
dos veces cero esto es cero otra vez
así es que esta sí es una variable libre
pero bueno ahorita seguimos con eso
después menos dos más dos por uno o sea
dos más dos
esto también es cero ya tenemos nuestra
entrada pivote cuatro más dos por menos
dos esos cuatro menos cuatro o sea
menos 12 más 2 x 4 eso es menos 12 más 8
o que yo sea menos 4 menos 4 esto se ve
muy interesante pero bueno a ver el
chiste es que aquí tenemos una entrada
pivote y aquí tenemos otra entrada
pivote y estas dos columnas o sea la
variable x2 y la variable x 4 parecen
ser variables libres pero pues vamos a
ver bien qué les pasa aquí tenemos que
nuestras entradas pivotes son uno muy
importante y hay puros ceros en la
columna de las variables pivote y esto
es una cuestión puramente de estilo pero
la segunda variable pivote está abajo ya
la derecha de la primera variable pivote
todo este bonche de números realmente
son puros números para mí así tal cual
está complicado interpretarlo por el
momento yo nada más tome la matriz
aumentada de coeficientes y la reduje a
su forma escalonada reducida como una
máquina tal cual como lo haría tu
computadora en algún programa pero si
queremos interpretar esto pues hay que
regresarnos al mundo de las ecuaciones
así es que a ver esta fila lo que me da
es una ecuación donde el coeficiente de
x 1 es 1 o sea x 1 es muy variable
pivote x 1 x 1 y luego como este 2 está
en la segunda columna tenemos 2 veces x
2 2 x x 20 veces la variable x 3 porque
estamos en la tercera columna + 0 x x 3
mejor dejo el espacio y después 3 x x 4
o sea 3 x 4 y nuestra línea del igual
y aquí del otro lado del igual 14
y la siguiente fila lo que nos da es 0
por x 100 por x2 01 por x 3 x 3 - 2 por
x 4 - 2 por x 4 y todo eso es igual a 4
igual a 4 y la tercera fila lo que nos
dice es 0 x x 1 + 0 x x 20 x x 3
+ 0 x x 4
y todo eso es igual a menos 4 ok
entonces esta última ecuación que es lo
que nos dice osea tal cual lo único que
tenemos 0 0 0 0 y pues lo que suman es
simplemente un solo 0 y lo que nos queda
aquí es algo que está súper mal lo que
nos queda es que 0 es exactamente igual
a 4 eso no nos puede pasar nunca esto
esto de aquí es simplemente imposible
esto es imposible el cero nunca nunca
puede ser igual a menos 4 y esto lo que
significa es que este sistema de
ecuaciones no tiene solución aunque hay
lo que significa es que las superficies
que representan las soluciones de cada
una de estas ecuaciones que como tenemos
tres ecuaciones tendríamos tres
superficies entre cuatro que esas tres
superficies de soluciones no se
intersectan o sea no hay ni un solo
punto en r4 que satisfaga las tres
ecuaciones porque r4 pues porque tenemos
cuatro variables desconocidas aquí está
uno
2 3 y 4 entonces nuestras soluciones son
digamos vectores x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4
y esto pues como son 4 y pueden ser
cualquier real están en r 4 y decimos
que un vector de estos en r 4 de
solución si a la hora de sustituir x 1
acá x 2 en cada una de estas ecuaciones
x 3 por acá y x 4 en cada uno de estos
valores
entonces se satisfacen estas ecuaciones
pero justo este resultado de que 0 es
igual a menos 4 lo que nos dice es que
ningún conjunto de cuatro valores sin
ningún vector en r4 satisface estas tres
ecuaciones al mismo tiempo así es que al
inicio del vídeo pensábamos que como
eran tres ecuaciones y sólo cuatro
variables desconocidas que entonces
tiene que haber una infinidad de
soluciones
pero ahorita nos acabamos de dar cuenta
que en realidad no hay ni una sola
solución y bueno eso es lo que pasa
siempre que en alguna de nuestras filas
de nuestra matriz aumentada hay apuros
ceros del lado izquierdo de la raya del
igual y algún valor distinto de cero del
lado derecho
es muy difícil visualizar o imaginarse
cosas en el recuadro pero imagínense en
r3 un plano como por acá y después otro
plano que no se intersecta con el ok
pero que esté así como que elevado
digamos que el mismo plano pero más
arriba
ok y además planos que nunca se
intersectan entonces por ejemplo un
plano puede ser 3 x + 6
9 z igual
5 y que el otro plano sea 3 x +
6 + 9 sep está igual a 2
estos son dos planos en r 3 en r3 que
son básicamente el mismo plano pero
desplazado en alguna dirección y por lo
mismo no se intersectan nunca y entonces
no hay ningún vector en r3 ningún vector
x etc que satisfaga estas dos ecuaciones
aunque hay porque tiene exactamente los
mismos coeficientes entonces si hay un
vector xz tal que 3 x + 6 y 9-7 es igual
a 5 a la hora de sustituirlo en esta
ecuación pues nos va a quedar que 3x
massey más 9 z es igual a 5 y por lo
tanto no puede ser igual a 2 ya la hora
de hacer la matriz aumentada de los
coeficientes y reducirla a su forma
escalonada reducida por filas lo que nos
va a quedar es una hilera de ceros igual
a menos 3 o sea aquí mismo lo podemos
vernos o sea sustituimos la segunda
ecuación por una vez la segunda ecuación
menos la primera
y los que da 0 x 0 y 0 z igual a 253 o
sea 0 igual a menos 3 y pues lo mismo
pasa en r 4 y en r 5 y r6 y así para
todos los seres siempre puede haber
superficies que no se intersectan y por
lo tanto puede haber sistemas de
ecuaciones que no tengan solución
entonces si nos queda 0 igual a algo
distinto de cero o sea si nos queda una
fila llena de ceros excepto la entrada
del otro lado del igual eso significa
que no hay solución
no hay solución así es que si hay menos
ecuaciones que variables desconocidas
eso no siempre significa que haya una
infinidad de soluciones lo que significa
es que hay una infinidad de soluciones o
no hay solución
así es que siempre que tratando de
resolver un sistema de ecuaciones nos
quede una ecuación que diga que cero es
igual a cualquier otra cosa que no sea
cero eso lo que significa es que no hay
solución gay no hay solución
por otro lado siempre que tengamos una
matriz escalonada reducida por filas en
la que en cada columna haya una entrada
pivote o sea por ejemplo aquí voy a
escribir una matriz de esa forma de ere
4 entonces el sistema de ecuaciones a la
que esta matriz aumentada está
representando tiene una única solución
ok pero bueno a ver aquí tenemos muchas
entradas pivot es una en cada columna y
por lo tanto en el resto de cada columna
o sea en el resto de las entradas tienen
que haber puros ceros
y de este el lado de la raya del igual
pues puede haber cualquier número real
que se nos ocurra por lo tanto vamos a
denotar los por letras aunque hay aquí
puede estar cualquier número al igual
que aquí y aquí y aquí y de todas formas
como en cada columna tenemos una entrada
pivote entonces hay una única solución
que hay una solución única ahora el
último caso que nos falta del cual de
hecho tenemos un ejemplo en el primer
vídeo de esta serie es en el que tenemos
una cantidad infinita de soluciones y su
matriz en su forma escalonada reducida
por fila se ve así aunque ahí tenemos la
primera fila con su entrada pivote no se
digamos que está como por acá y aquí
quién sabe que tenemos y la segunda fila
pues vamos a ponerle que su entrada
pivote no está en la segunda columna
sino en la tercera no sé aquí que tiene
un cero y un cero y un cero y pues como
estas son entradas pivote entonces aquí
tiene que ver ceros
ok y finalmente no sé digamos que hay un
1 nada más al azar podría haber un 0
como sea
pongámoslo un 0 por acá aquí
definitivamente tiene que haber un 0
porque esta es la siguiente entrada
pivote y aquí podríamos tener una
entrada pivote pero pues también la
podemos dejar con su entrada 0 aquí
puede estar exactamente el número que se
nos ocurra vamos a ponerle menos 3 aquí
también deberíamos de ponerle una b o
una o algo así pero vamos a ponerle un 7
y lo que sí es muy importante es que
aquí ya no lo podemos poner la entrada
que se nos ocurra porque de este lado
tenemos puros ceros entonces dependiendo
de que pongamos aquí va a haber una
infinidad de soluciones o no va a haber
solución pero como aquí ya está el caso
en el que no hay solución pues aquí
vamos a ponerle un cero para que si haya
solución entonces aquí tenemos una
entrada pivote aquí tenemos la segunda
entrada pivote
estas dos columnas
que no tienen ni una sola entrada pivote
igual esta no tiene entrada pivote en
ningún lado de esta columna por lo cual
representa una variable libre que pueden
tomar el valor que se les ocurra y como
aquí esta entrada de acá si es un cero
entonces si hay solución por lo tanto
como tenemos dos variables libres
entonces tenemos una infinidad de
soluciones infinidad de soluciones así
es que siempre que tengas una matriz y
que las reduzcas a su forma escalonada
reducida por filas te vas a encontrar
con alguno de estos tres casos y bueno
espero que te parezca útil esta tabla y
estos vídeos